hi guys videos have been around for
years as a really good source of
entertainment as a way of telling
narratives and stories of getting
audience system around the world amassed
in kind of an environment and a
narrative that has come out of someone's
head and is brilliant for that as well I
love film that's why I love YouTube
anyone from around the world can just
use this video platform as their
creative outlet if they have a narrative
in their head if they have a meaning
that wants to get across to the public
it can easily be done through video
however it lacks interactivity doesn't
it you're just a person and the screen
and whatever happens happens so what's
been happening recently is a lot of
interactive videos have been being made
through things like WebGL but I wanted
to see how I could make my own version
of an interactive video I wanted to
create a world that is told through
video formats but it also really makes
the audience feel more immersed in that
world it's not just on the screen it is
in the reality that is around them so
let me explain how I brought this vision
to life basically starts with this
character that I concocted called Terra
he is the protagonist to a story well a
poem that I wrote all about who is Tara
I wanted to the meaning at the end of
who is Tara to come across as well as
possible you're probably guessing who
terror is by now you can see my normal
video form of this video so check that
out and it will probably make more sense
you can come back here and you can see
how I turned that video into an
interactive experience that was
exhibited in the vasa PI creative
technologist program exhibition because
this video was to be exhibited in a
physical space
I didn't simply want it to be a
choose-your-own-adventure video because
I didn't want people to be coming in
halfway through and not really
understanding the narrative as a video
content creator as a filmmaker as even a
writer or anything to do with narratives
do you know that you really want the
narrative to come across to your viewer
because you put a lot
I'm an effort into it and to have
someone come in halfway through and not
know a Dickey bear of what's going on
and just say oh that's a cool video in
it it's not what you want so I wanted to
make a space where everyone could come
and explore the narrative from start to
finish and really get the full
experience so to make them half the full
experience I wanted to make the
exhibition space that I had luckily I
had a room all to myself so this was
good I wanted to make it fit the theme
and obviously the theme was a bit spooky
it was a bit scary it was to bring you
back to your childhood fears of monsters
under the bed things like that that you
don't really get scared of when you're
older or maybe you do but you don't
admit to it what I did was I brought
some stars I had put in the video and
put them up above by the projector so
they were kind of hanging from the
ceiling I painted this doll's house that
was also used when I filmed the video
and put it on a table in front of the
video that was being projected onto a
wall I also made some pop-up trees
around the house I had a backdrop and
the backdrop was the same design as what
I'd used in video I really hope you've
seen the video but the video the video
was about this gal who's reading a book
but she finds herself within the book I
used projection to show her walking
through the scenes of the book so it was
as if she was walking through the actual
illustrations of the book if you want to
see a video on how I did all of that
then watch watch this video here because
this video is all about the
interactivity so that was the idea
carrying on with the technical talk as
well as the physical objects that mimics
the look and feel and style of the video
that they were watching I wanted them to
interact with the physical objects as if
the video had seeped into the real world
this was on the table in front of them
and not only was it there for show it
was there for them to actually interact
with they could open the door to reveal
Tara inside he's not in there at the
moment there were lights and sighs that
made it more entrancing the speakers
were placed with
in the house so when they heard the
sounds of the video it would come from
in the house so curiosity would
hopefully get the better of them and
they'd want to know more about the
physical house that was sat right in
front of them instead of being a passive
viewer and just watching the video on
the wall behind the house what I
physically needed to make this an
interactive video was irazu by the rasli
pi is basically just a tiny tiny
computer it could fit right inside the
house so that was good I also had some
speakers and there cuz you need some
audio right the Razzie PI has some GPIO
pins so I could attach this to a
breadboard and then attach that to my
two buttons I also had to use the Razzie
PI camera which is really easy to use
add-on that just sits on the Raspberry
Pi board I position that behind a cutout
of Tara I also used a motion sensor for
the ending of the video the end product
ended up being a physical object which
was a painted doll's house which held
the Razzie pi as well as an object of
terror and the speaker's of course the
video was played from an HDMI cable that
ran from the browser PI straight into
you a projector that was projected onto
the wall now using two buttons from the
GPIO pins of the Raspberry Pi one button
could play the video the other button
was a button that could be pressed if
you felt brave enough when this button
was pressed
it would pause the video at whatever
point the video was playing at and it
would play a live streamed footage of
the Razzie PI camera within the house
with an overlay image of a close-up of
Tara's eyes so you could see that it was
peering out at you slightly as well as
this it would also play a sound clip of
breathing that you could hear within the
house and it was so unnerving it was
brilliant to see how unnerved people
were by that now one thing I noticed
from this is a lot of people didn't even
realize that it was live streamed
footage they thought it was just an
image but then once they started moving
around or peering with in the house they
would see the shadows move and then
realize oh damn this is live stream
footage this is the thing that's
actually looking at me and it was
great to see now this once - at the end
of the video I changed it slightly for
the interactive experience it coerced
the viewer to open the physical door to
find out who is Tara do you dare that is
the question
once they did they could see a physical
cutout of Terror within the door but it
had a motion sensor within the house
that would open up the camera which was
just behind terror and show their face
blown up on the screen it then asked
them to press a button and that picture
will be sent straight to Twitter there
who is Tara Twitter profile with a
caption I am Tara and then put in the
illustrations that I had made go onto
the Twitter feed it will be in the
description below and you can watch
everyone's reactions of how they felt
after realizing that they were Tara and
it was just brilliant some really funny
reactions seriously it just go so
obviously I need to do a bit of
programming for all of this what I used
for the programming side was GPIO 0
which is Razzie PI's own interface for
their GPIO pins I mean it's so much
easier to use the motion sensor and the
buttons cuz it's really simple to use
and they've got great documentation I
will be putting all of this in the
description below I also used MX player
which is a video player from Rossi PI's
GPU and the exact library that I used
was Python or MX wrapper now to send the
image to the surcin Twitter account I
need to set up a Twitter account get a
Twitter app which is quite easily done
there's a lot of documentation out there
on how to do that and then I used tweet
pea and image magic to tweet the photo
and also lay over my overlay of my own
illustrations this actually I found from
a brilliant blog post by rasp ITV which
again will be in the description below
so go check all about for an in-depth
description on how I coded this how I
put it all together please look in the
description for a blog post where I've
written all about it and also on my
github for where I have stored the code
this was in no means easy but it was so
so fun and I really want to carry on
exploring with different ways that you
can make an interactive video I think
having a physical object that mimicked
the video really helped for people to
feel involved and engaged in the
narrative and it was great to see
different people interact with it in
their own ways so many people weren't
used to being able to interact with the
video they didn't want to press a button
because they didn't want to stop the
video playing they were worried they'd
miss out on something they just weren't
used to it because as a viewer you just
sit down and you simply watch and you
have to kind of coax them and it's it's
very interesting to see some people who
are more curious who just wanted to play
around with it as much as possible and
others who really wanted to stay in the
norm bubble of just watching a video
simply and appreciating it which is
lovely as well and at the end when they
were coaxed to open up the door it was
so funny to see the amount of people who
were too scared to open the door who
would get their friends to do it who
would get their mom to do it and it just
meant that it worked that having this
physical object that mimics the
narrative and the emotions and
everything else felts within the video
really made them feel that way as well
because they were being asked to do
something they weren't just watching it
and it wasn't just in the screen it was
in the room with them and they had to
physically do something to progress the
knowledge of who is terror and I think
it was amazing it was just an awesome
experience to create something make it
interactive and see people interact with
it in an actual exhibition space so I
really hope to do more if you want to
talk to me about interactive videos or
share with me an idea or even something
that you've done please I would love to
hear what you have to say you can email
me on Yasmin Kern at gmail.com be in
touch anyway I really hope
enjoyed this explanation of my thought
processes when creating an interactive
video hopefully it's been inspiring or
at least just kind of interesting to
find out if you want to know more in
depth knowledge about all of this please
check the links in the description below
and leave a thumbs up if you found this
fun have a look at your evening bye
in a dim dark Street of a dim dark city
in a dim dark house of that dim dark
Street in a dim dark bedroom of that dim
doghouse